measures of dispersion describe how
spread out the values in a data set are
measures of dispersion are for example
variance standard deviation range and
Inter quartile range let's start with
the standard deviation the standard
deviation indicates the average distance
between each data point and the mean but
slowly each person has some deviation
from the mean now we want to know how
much the persons deviate from the mean
value on average to calculate the
standard deviation we can use this
equation Sigma is the standard deviation
n is the number of persons x e is the
size of each person and x dash is the
mean value of all persons but attention
there are two slightly different
equations for the standard deviation to
keep it simple simple if our survey
doesn't cover the whole population we
always use this equation likewise if we
have conducted a clinical study then we
also use this equation to infer the
population but what is the difference
between the standard deviation and the
variance as we now know the standard
deviation is the quadratic mean of the
distance from the mean the variance now
is the square standard deviation if you
want to know more about the standard
deviation and the variance please watch
our video let's go to the range and the
interquartile range it is easy to
understand the range is simply the
difference between the minimum and the
maximum value the inter quartile range
represents the middle 50% of the data it
is the difference between the third
quartile Q3 and the first quartile q1
therefore 25% of the values are smaller
than the interquartile range and 25% of
the values are larger the interquartile
range contains exactly the middle 50% of
all values let's briefly compare
measures of central tendency and
measures of dispersion let's say we
measure the blood pressure of patients
measures of central tendency provide a
single value that represents the entire
data set helping to identify a central
value around which data points tend to
Cluster measures of dispersion like the
standard deviation the range and the
interquartile range indicate how spread
out the data points are whether they are
closely packed around the center or
spread far from it in summary while
measures of central tendency provide a
central point point of the data set
measures of dispersion describe how the
data set is spread around that Center I
hope you enjoyed the video